welcome back 6 22 it is the unauthorized
experience of one of pop culture's most
popular magical stories
every week at valleys you can revisit
the harry potter story in a way that
you've never experienced before and so
excited to bring these guys here on the
show this morning the cast of potted
potter james edwards nicholas charles
glad you guys are here i know it's very
early we appreciate you the earliest
i've been up in three years in las vegas
yeah yeah you're welcome everybody
the show kicked off in 2018 and i know
kovid shut everything down but it has
just been a huge success uh yeah it's
coming up on about four years now in
valleys uh celebrating almost 600 shows
you've just said
and uh it's been it's been such a fun
time like all all throughout the times
that we've been together it's been it's
been amazing good fun for the all the
kids that show up all the families that
come
uh just making people laugh is it's not
a bad job not a bad gig no not at all
especially everyone needs a good laugh
now it is a parody if you could describe
for folks who maybe aren't familiar with
potted potter what it is that you do
because there is just two people on
stage
that's correct yes so uh james has a
lovely job of being harry potter
easy job i get the lump task of playing
everybody else
so uh yeah we do seven books in 70
minutes so if my math is right also 10
minutes a book yeah roughly we play a
whole game of quidditch yeah yeah okay
yeah so if you come along bring your
broom because you'll need it uh-huh and
so she's the wind at the moment you'll
be flying around valleys fantastic yeah
you might end up in another stadium
it's kid-friendly it's family-friendly
we have people from all generations my
favorite thing is when you see granddad
grandma the kids everybody's here
yeah bring your harry potter t-shirts
yeah i'll see you there now what about
the folks who aren't quite muggles they
haven't they haven't read the books they
haven't watched the movies can they
still experience this and and kind of
understand what's going on fortunately
yes we do we do a fantastic job of uh of
giving love and admiration to each harry
potter book but uh
with some hints of pop culture in there
each show is slightly different where
there's a little reference to something
current and something harry potter that
either a niche fan would love or that
someone else could just laugh at in
general because it's funny
there's definitely some jokes if you
have a book that will go over your head
but you do not need to be you know a
super duper fan okay and uh we basically
books are boring come see us come just
we'll relive the whole show
okay so and obviously you're playing
harry playing everybody else have you
guys ever done that online uh hat
sorting the the contest where you find
out which harry potter uh you know which
house you want yeah have you done it i i
am quite a nerd yes i've done it what
would you end up with uh for all my
fellow listeners out there ravenclaw
okay okay team random tour in the house
team ravenclaw wit beyond measure oh
that's what it is
i'm hufflepuff which i guess is
puffed before
huffle i think those those are good ones
those are good ones i've taken it a few
times i get different ones every time
yesterday came up with slytherin and i
was a little distressed about it i know
i was kind of surprised
i need to be ravenclaw or hufflepuff i
think that that's probably the good way
to go um okay so you guys are at bally's
and you're performing uh every night
except wednesday you're dark on
wednesday that's it yeah we do uh we
have on the weekends we double up so we
do 2 p.m and 8 p.m so if you've got
younger kids we're an afternoon show you
come see us then and if you want to come
for the rowdy eight o'clock crowd that's
always fun uh that's where the
broomsticks come out huh that's when
quidditch gets quite competitive
ticket prices
it really depends on the day okay
kind of all over the place
okay good stuff all right so folks at
home if you haven't seen potted potter
these are the guys you got to see
whether or not you've read the books or
seen the movies this parody is uh is a
great one and you guys have won a lot of
awards for for it we did yes las vegas
2019. awesome awesome awesome okay well
you guys awesome james nicholas thank
you so much for being on the show this
morning hey folks stick around we